[Music]
how long we've known each other chin I
ever break a promise to you I will put
you in the driver's seat at Lamar you
just shut your mouth and let me do my
thing
all right morning Shelby warning Molly
fuels now go to help
that's it folks Ferrari wins - 24 hours
of LaVon for the fifth consecutive year
mr. Ford Ferrari has a message for you
sir what did they say he said for it
makes ugly little cars and ugly
factories and God you fat sir we're
gonna bury Ferrari at LeMond so the
great house Shelby is gonna build a car
to beat Ferrari with a foreword correct
and how long did you tell them you
needed two or three hundred years 90
days who hates guys like us because
we're different we heard he's difficult
Jim no no Ken's a puppy dog
[Music]
itself oh there's a problem the computer
will find out you get some scotch tape
and a ball of wool what are they doing
making your car faster
and miles it's not afford man we're on
the verge of something and now you tell
me that I can't have the best man in the
world behind the wheel give me one
reason why I don't fire everyone
starting with you well sir the lighter
work faster that don't work we're
nastier go ahead girl go to war I risk I
thought the whole point was to win the
top trace
if this were a beauty pageant
we just lost looks aren't everything in
the last three years you and your
marketing team have presided over the
worst sales slump in US history why
exactly should mr. Ford listen to you
because we've been thinking wrong
Ferrari now they've won four out of the
last five LeMond we need to think like
Ferrari Ferrari makes fewer cars in a
year than we make in a day we spend more
on toilet paper
than they do on their entire output you
want us to think like them
Enzo Ferrari will go down in history as
the greatest car manufacturer of all
time why is it because he built the most
cars it's because of what his cars mean
victory Ferrari wins that LeMans people
they they want some of that victory
where's the Ford badge meant victory and
many wear counts with the first group of
17 year olds in history with money in
their pockets this would take years
decades to test and develop a race team
capable of taking a Ferrari
Ferraris bankrupt
and so I spent every lure he's got
chasing perfection you know something he
got there now he's broken think I'll
just push the car hot I'll wait right
that's right you have to be kind to the
car you feel the poor thing groaning
underneath you if you're gonna push a
piece of machinery to the limit and
expect it to hold together you have to
have some sense of where that limit is
look out there out there is the perfect
lap no mistakes every gear change every
corner
perfect you see it
[Music]
I think so
most people can't
most people don't even know it's out
there but it is
[Music]
is there
another satisfied customer
help you miss wasn't that an mga 1500 ah
you know your cars
I like them I love the sound they make
where it goes right through you
that vibration lines the wood panelled
country squire across the street
a real hot rock death oh yeah is it fast
very wait a second what type of girl are
you type a girl who likes the smell of
gasoline oh well are you some kind of a
deviant yeah yeah Mary do you nothing in
there about my trunk and your lovely
little portmanteau you're holding the 62
edition of the SCCA you can stick this
bloody sticker hey Jim what seems to be
the problem is that bill here he didn't
mean the bill isn't silly I'm just doing
my job
Phil Phil Phil in my experience there is
listen to me something like this there's
always a middle ground all right now
Ken's out of line and I understand you
are you know how he gets on a race day
you know that all right but you're not
gonna DQ us over the trunk
Harvey bill yeah I am mr. Shelby what's
it take to win the 24 hours of the mine
you need a pure racer behind a wheeler
car as Kent miles
this is a wonderful era in motor racing
history but is more than a racing movie
all right here we go the movie does a
really wonderful job of showing the two
guys who were very different didn't come
together and attempted to do the
impossible it's high-risk extremely
high-risk
the odds are against them and despite
that they know what it's like to persist
and they never give up this is a
crossroads in both of their lives it's
incredibly relatable you do taste make
sure it's for the six you really feel
what's at stake together we're gonna
make history
there are a few people who find
something they have to do some obsesses
them
I'm that guy and I know one other man
feels exactly the same and together
we're gonna make good for you this movie
is really a pretty classic underdog
story you're gonna build a car to beat
Ferrari with a fool correct the story
follows this relationship between
Carroll Shelby and 10-miles who shall be
just thought was indispensable know
whatever it is she'll know trust me I
think the movie is about more than car
racing it's a movie about Brotherhood
and the things we accomplish in
collaboration with others
[Music]
they aren't the people that you'd say
alright these guys are gonna go dominate
the world stage
they need each other to attempt to do
the impossible
[Music]
there's a point 7000rpm
you seen becomes weightless
7000rpm that's where you made it
this movie is really a pretty classic
underdog story you're gonna build a car
to beat Ferrari with a fully correct and
how long did you tell them that you
needed to three hundred years it's 90
days the story follows this relationship
between Carroll Shelby and Ken miles who
shall be just felt was indispensable
it's a movie about friendship and the
things we accomplish in collaboration
with others this isn't the first time
Lord motors gone war we know how to do
more than push paper go ahead kill go to
war thank you sir this is a crossroads
in both of their lives they need each
other keep this up the car do you think
he can beat
woman was the ultimate test many cars in
even survived
to go down the Mulsanne straight at 230
miles an hour and really not know if
your brakes were gonna work these guys
were always one blink of an eye away
from death that's an extraordinary story
[Music]